joining me now to analyze is Gordon
Chang columnist and author of the book
the coming collapse of China Gordon
where do you see this going you and I
have talked about this idea that it's
crazy for us to trade with China at all
given their strategic ambitions to you
know push us out as the world's dominant
military and economic power the
president actually seemed to even float
that concept today do you know the
markets are pretty jittery the last
couple of days but where do things stand
now
well things stand now at a point where
the Chinese are not talking to us you
know it was really interesting at the
Osaka g20 President Trump and si Jinping
the Chinese ruler negotiated an interim
deal that actually was very favorable
for China it gave them a critical
concession on Huawei and the Chinese
agreed to buy more AG products which
they have to do anyway from somebody
well you know CJ and ping couldn't even
honor that Laura and I think that it
says that in Beijing right now there is
political paralysis something is really
wrong and you know you can't negotiate
with the Chinese right now so I think
President Trump is absolutely right you
know if these guys don't want to talk to
us in good faith well we'll just go on
without them and you know that's really
where we need to be to disengage boycott
well and China apparently according to
Fox News has some sources report coming
out that China says it looks like it's
moving toward an effort to decouple from
the United States but how realistic is
that Gordon when you have Germany's
economy essentially flat Frances and all
this turmoil the yellow vests brexit
still not determine a lot of tumult in
in you know in Britain I mean there's no
other economy that's really strong in
the world right now of the big countries
other than the United States so how does
China decouple is that just kind of a
tit-for-tat thing
yeah well it's China can't really
decouple I mean last year China's
merchandised surplus with the u.s.
accounted for a hundred and nineteen
point three percent of its overall
merchandise surplus that is incredible
dependence on the US you know we have an
economy Laura that is not export
dependent certainly not dependent on
China but China has an economy dependent
on
that means we've got a lot of leverage
you had a lot of smart people in the
u.s. saying oh you know China in the
u.s. can't decouple well one thing we've
seen this year is that China is becoming
much less of an actor for us
yeah Gordon thank you so much great to
see you as always